the u.s capitol building
under siege thousands of president
donald trump's followers surrounded the
building
and burst in the result a remarkable
scene of lawmakers fleeing
and the police seemingly overwhelmed
social media filled with pictures of
trump's followers and offices
in the chambers running free in what is
supposed to be one of the most protected
buildings in the country
it started as u.s president donald trump
called his supporters to protest
what he falsely claimed was a stolen
election
riling them up with inflammatory words
and misinformation
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
as a joint session of congress met to
certify the election the president's
followers heeded his words
and descended on the capitol chaos
followed
tear gas and flashbangs to try and push
them back from the front of the capitol
others moved to the back quickly pushing
through a line of police
many entering the building congress was
dismissed and its members fled
at one point reports of an armed
standoff at least one protester was shot
and killed several officers injured the
incoming president responded
this is not dissent it's disorder
it's chaos it borders on sedition
and it must end now
i call on this mob to pull back and
allow the work of democracy to go
forward he demanded the president tell
his supporters to go
home and trump did but continued to
repeat his lies
i know your pain i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen from
us
it was a landslide election and everyone
knows it
as night fell on the u.s capitol the
national guard the police they tried to
regain control
of the building in the morning it will
bring fresh questions about exactly
how this happened and whether there'll
be any repercussions for the people
whose words
led to this unbelievable action patti
culhane al jazeera at the u.s capitol